here's we work a company
that decides to go public through a spec
deal right we all know what we work is
we work is essentially what it's it's
office space right if you want a bunch
of businesses coming together
and we work in the same office space
together which by the way brilliant idea
they were killing it i mean everybody
was talking about it
sort of a cool version of regis for the
moment
exactly right they get old regions old
old buildings that they would never do
yeah exactly so the office sharing
startup plans for its high-profile ipo
imploded spectacularly in october 2019
due to widespread
criticism over its business model and
its founder adam newman's management
style
we work at hell talks with at least
three blank check firm spanx
over the past two months cautioning that
the current talks could fall apart we
have specs approaching
on a weekly basis we work executive
chairman
marcelo clark said who used to be with
sprint wework was valued at 47
billion dollars in 2019 but saw its
valuation plummet to roughly 8 billion
after softbank was forced to extend the
life-saving
financing lifeline at wework
so the the part everybody has to realize
is even before the pandemic these guys
were having problems they fired out of
newman they laid off 2 400 employees
they lost billions of dollars and then
comes coronavirus they get
crushed tom do you think these guys can
recover from it and be a business model
that's profitable
that people would want to invest in
i i don't know i mean marcelo clare has
basically done more
stabilization than innovation he
stabilized things
and they're trying to get out with a
story
but you know what's really interesting i
think it the whole thing they're waiting
for people to go back from
work from home to use office again
because wework was about
hey if you if you step back and look at
wework they were for gen z
the open lobby everybody gets to hang
out together you know there's a word for
that in covit it's called super spreader
so i i don't know they got to convince
people that that business model is going
to work and that businesses are going to
come back
and want open areas where people can
hang out by the coffee machine
learn from each other in each business
have their own little private idaho in
there
but i i think softbank i mean softbank
that 47 million things softbank hit hard
wall
you know that was not fun and so i think
they
want to get out and they almost have to
get out to the market so they can
you know put this money in the bank but
they got to prove to everybody there's a
real business there
would you invest in we work right now
nope like are you
buy sell hold neutral i've got great
respect for softbank but i think they're
in a very hard place
why are they doing it though these are
smart people why are they getting into
it
put your hat on and say what
alternatives do they have right
they need capital to run this this is
continuing to run at a loss
even before the pandemic so how can
rents be up that they're actually making
a buck
is this if if soft bank is
deciding to do something like this is
this a good sign for everybody else to
say
that if a company like softbank views
everything going back to normal if
they're risking money like this to
invest into a company
that's a mess like wework is because of
what happened in 2019 and the fact that
pandemic crushed them
i'm not even talking about the issues
prior to on the adam newman's management
style
let's set that aside i'm just talking
about the consequences of what kovit did
to we work absolutely if they're
investing are they indirectly saying
we feel the future looks bright
everything's going to go back to normal
i i for me this is this if you're going
to ask me to invest in
i know when am i putting my retirement
savings that i know that needs
to be there when i retire no i'm not
doing am i putting a little bit of my
money towards of course i would because
i believe in the the we work uh uh
office sharing
uh platform uh we we've got a bunch in
uh in downtown chicago um at the
merchandise mart and uh uh just a bunch
of
incubating um entrepreneurs are there i
think the
the the attraction back again of again
back to the connection
because you can't really connect with
people on zoom and i think if you're
going to connect uh uh with other
entrepreneurs of people that are
are incubating too as well in that phase
of their business a wework type of
operation grows um they got uh they got
some spacks uh approaching them
you know you know the the type of money
is that's being thrown in this direction
i take a whim at it um if i'm an
incubating entrepreneur today i'd be
looking for a weworks uh type of
office sharing platform to start my
business so yeah interesting if
if you're watching this i'm actually
curious right now okay let's take a look
at this we got 217 thumbs up kai i don't
know if you're seeing it
we got 217 thumbs up right now no thumbs
down by the way appreciate the love if
you're with us and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
and some of you that think you already
are subscribed this is a different
channel it's a pbd podcast channel so
click that subscribe button under
notification but i got a question for
you i got a question for you
thumbs up if you are fully comfortable
going back to work and being around
others
you know where you know how it was in
2019 are you like i cannot wait to go
to a fully environment thumbs down if
you're saying it's reckless we're
starting way too early we should take
our time so
smash thumbs up if you say yes we got to
get back to work and being around each
other thumbs down if you don't so we
have 217
and zero i'm actually curious to know
what happens to it so far
uh uh voting with that most people are
saying they want to get back to work do
you see that only two people
so far have said no most of the world
not what the media tells you
not what the you know focus groups of a
certain niche group of people tell you
right by the way 321 to 1. think about
that
that means 104 people voted thumbs up
one person said i don't want to go back
to work so to the person that said you
don't want to go back to work
do you mind commenting below and saying
why okay now we went to five
let us know why you're uncomfortable of
going back is it the fear of you know
kovit being contagious is it the fear of
uh
uh you know what if i get sick and
what's happening right now with
different schools or different places
and you know it's the spread that's
taking place in different places
it's happening right now we had a
conversation with a couple schools that
are going through it in texas
that this is taking place we experience
it ourselves
or or is it just something where the
tipping point is
i just don't want to work in an
environment anymore because a part of
this i know certain people who are
introverts
that they would love to work from home
for the rest of their lives exactly they
would love to not be around other people
they would love so
how much of this is revealing
the extroverts and the introverts okay
yeah how much of this is revealing
who has always wanted to work from home
and they never wanted to be around
others they would much rather do their
work and not go to a work environment
and how much of it is you know i'm just
scared wanting to go back
i'm curious people have asked you in
many many conversations uh you know
because you know you get
distracted all the time by all these
different ways to make money online
all these different ways to do
e-commerce many different ways to run a
business from
behind the computer the the four-hour
workweek type of person right
now you too can run an amazon drop ship
business
and so i've i asked you and if you could
share with the the viewers and the
listeners here
what your answer was to me because um
because i asked can we really run an
insurance operation grow an insurance
operation
or any business operation that requires
people to be working together
with something that sustains and lasts
and creates generational wealth
can we do this from behind a computer
and your answer to me was
if you know if you want to build
something that lasts man i think you
need to
you need to be around and build
something together cohesively as a team
in an environment what do your uh can
you consider
i always i always battle with one thing
let me tell you what it is i remember
one time
you know reading an article about you
know here's what's the mistake of
millennials and here's how they are and
here's the gender he's just talking
about the younger generation all the
problems that they have
but the sentence it ended with this is
time magazine
the sentence it ended with was
but then again if you are complaining
about millennials
maybe it's because you're getting older
okay because
every generation told us that
these men like elvis presley who are
shaking their hips
you know this is not good for our kids
and our daughters they should not see a
man
move his hips the way he does this is
not appropriate it's not the
conservative thing
elvis presley was you know moving his
hips and girls were going crazy
yeah that's right right my music makes
me move so
so you got you got that so the older
generation you know i'm i'm not 42 which
means i'm young enough to
connect to the 20 30 year olds but i'm
yeah i'm young enough to connect to
uh uh the 20 to 30 but also at the same
time old enough where it's 50 years
you know just 10 years and 60 is right
there it's not like you know when i was
20 the
today 60 year olds were 40 when i was 30
they were 50 when i'm 42 they're 60
right so
we're right in the middle so for us to
say you know
the zoo model is the only way to go is
the old school model
that also means maybe we're not adapting
with the time it also means maybe we're
getting too old and we're not willing to
adjust and see what the the directions
are maybe the younger generation's got
something to teach us
and we have to realize this is something
that is going to be here to stay but at
the same time
at the same time at the same time
how many times have you gone to
someone's
house where the kid has been what's the
word i'm looking for
where they are isolated isolated from
everybody their entire lives because the
parents are so paranoid and i'm not even
talking about covet
i'm just talking about parents who
hardcore isolate their kids
from everything and you talk to the kid
how are you good
how's your day today good so
what's your favorite thing to do video
games
what so i don't know yeah i don't know
right you see right yeah
so so i'm like dude like where's the
soul man
let me let me like where's the conflict
where's where's so how do you get that
the only way you get that is what to be
around other people you know
what makes us different from animals is
we can respond we can communicate we
have a way of talking to each other we
can create we can
work together as a community so i think
both as needed and i'm kind of glad
microsoft is doing the survey by the way
i love when companies do a survey
that some parts of the survey it
contradicts their own business model
and for these guys to own what they have
to say hey we got to kind of get back to
work
it makes sense but we we will not know
the consequences of the way we handle
covid
and the isolation it'll take a minimum a
decade
or two to see it because a six-year-old
that was going to school is going to be
26 one day
16 and 10 years you ain't gonna know
what this is gonna do to him right now
right
is he gonna make a full recovery is he
not that's that's the one part we don't
know someone no matter what
anybody says experts any doctor anybody
says
none of us know what is really going to
happen
10 years from now the whole thing with
the vaccine when i talk to certain
people that don't want to take it
like yesterday one of our friends jose
he goes to the hotel and she says
this 22 year old girl is like i can't
wait to take the vaccine and then
everything can get
sir please be careful touching that you
know you don't want to get sick
and then jose asked the lady says can i
ask you a question says yeah
so what's in the vaccine she says well i
i think it's all good stuff and she says
uh he says
when you eat do you not look at the
label on what's in it yeah
don't you think it's a good idea for you
to also know what's in the vaccine
i guess that makes sense well we don't
know what's in the vaccine
so so the people that are uncomfortable
with the vaccine and i know we're making
a big push right now he biting talked
about yesterday going to 200 million
right he's already done 100 he wants 200
million in the first 100 days
100 million in the first 85 days the
challenge with us
is we also don't know what's going to
happen with this vaccine side effects
for decades you're not going to know
what's going on there's some side
effects that could be a decade two days
about the military shots we took when
we're in look what happened to us
you know so we have no idea what those
shots were that we took so
we are not really going to know the side
effect of the level of isolation and
people working from home
for for quite some time kids and some
adults tom do you have any feedback on
this
yeah i do i think i think you make some
great points and
right now i look at it like this it's
not binary but the news
media looking for the story kind of
treats it as binary like all work from
home or not
and i think what happened is business
found a way to make it work and make it
work profitably
and we found certain parts of business
that like um you know
coders could be working remotely still
on a team be very effective
but the human interaction and the
culture of the business can't be
communicated over zoom
and so i i think it's not binary and i
think one of the things we're going to
find out later
to your point we're all going to look
back at that and find out that maybe
culture
and the humanness is lost even though oh
my coding worked well i made a profit
that year everything got done
i i don't think we're going to know for
about 10 years we're going to look back
and we're going to see
wow did we lose that we lose that
interconnection
you know long before i'll tell you
something long before
you know gofundmes if somebody
of um that that didn't make as much as
other people
lost a relative or something we did go
fund me we took collections in the
office we said wow you know this has run
ahead
yeah this is an only child who's going
to be responsible for burying their
uncle and has got all this
stuff so we would pass the hat and then
have like hr
quietly say your co-workers have risen
up to kind of help you out here we did a
good
that is a cultural moment for that
person and there's a lot of that stuff i
think is going to be lost and to your
point i think it is going to be 10 years
what do you think you look at your
insurance agency now and a year ago
where do you think the impact is i mean
i'm i'm thinking that where i
got stuck on in terms of the vaccine was
if if sheena was pregnant today
would i trust her to take the vaccine
and my answer is no
i agree it went out it went out so
quickly what was it three months of
testing
so how do they find willing pregnant
women
to do a true test across the
developmental nine-month flow of a child
to see with micro doses to see if
something's up yeah 100
pb what do you think uh i i we will find
out here
in the next few years on what's going to
happen we're going to find out what's
going to happen next few years i think
one thing i do bank on
is the ability for human beings to adapt
and some adapt faster some some adapt
slower
those who adapt slower typically are led
and respond to who those who adapt
faster similar to what happened in
sports
everybody responded to what dana white
did everybody's shutting stuff down dana
white said we're going on an island and
they said well maybe we got to do it and
then orlando opened up and they said
we're going to do the bubble basketball
so people so there's typically one
person that goes out there and does it
and he's a risk he's got the biggest
risk to take because if he screws up
everyone's going to say i told you not
to do it
but he's also got the highest potential
of being a hero because if he wins
everybody says damn he's smart look what
he did
let's follow his suit so we're going to
see right there's going to be companies
that are going to open up and they're
going to get hard core
criticism from the marketplace
and then there's going to be companies
that are not going to open up that
they're going to get what
hardcore support and empathetic oh my
gosh you're so wonderful for doing what
you're doing
one of them is going to be a hero and
one of them is not
in the next year or two years we're
going to look at one and we're going to
say wow good for them
they knew what those guys were too
scared or vice versa we'll see what's
going to be happening so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you